you  before we go a little built in Arkansas  is on a mission to brighten the lives of  other kids across the state  [Music]  Oh Rock eight-year-old Amelie ELISA way  is collecting night lights for other  children for children who are in foster  care she hopes that it'll help kids feel  more at home so far Amelia has given out  more than 500 night lights she spent the  past year setting up lemonade stands  planting planting school fundraisers and  hosting cook-offs to raise the money  sometimes if you get moved homes and you  don't get to bring everything so I  thought that maybe if you brought a  light nightlight when they sleeping it  would probably help them that's so sweet  her mom Lauren says Amelia learned that  you are never too young to make a  difference what a great idea because  that really I can always take with you  pop it in and feels like home very nice  to me Leah special mommy hug to you  that'll do it for us we'll see you  tomorrow take it easy